so that's a more embarrassing at 15 and
17 well actually started from 14 to 22.
this this young lady not 22 to 21 20.
until i went to college she hated me
yeah oh oh my god oh my god that's hold
on hold on oh my god that's what i'm
going through so so my daughter hates
you no
do you hate him jackie i don't even know
you
i'll tell you want to know something
crazy no but she i ended up in therapy
because of it she hated me it was
horrible my so my daughters um
i've i'm i
i learn i'm learning a lot
because my behavior when they mess up my
behavior of how they how i reacted when
they mess up you know like little
typical kid stuff sneaking out or
whatever my behavior my reaction was up
here yeah so then i forced them into a
paradigm where they had to then lie to
me because well that's like that's what
that's exactly that was our life
is the older one
more mad at you than the younger yeah
because you're learning
yeah i'm the oldest okay so the oldest
one right now there's my daughter's see
that's our christmas card
look how bad she is she's
that was me my whole life yeah so um so
much so that she wouldn't even mention
that i was her father oh do you know
that
she had a girlfriend in her house once
how old were you that was younger that
was younger
she lets people come to her house and my
oldest won't have her friends over at
our house she did i only when he went on
tour when he went out of town my friends
came over
yeah wow only when my mom was like that
is
a mirror to my family yeah your future
is you're going to be doing a podcast
with your daughter uh she's my daughter
george is
hilariously brilliant so smart
and uh but i we're exactly the same
she's yes
[Laughter]
she's not uh she's not i mean when i
went to the kings game with them that
king's picture yeah um they they brought
me over to do an interview and of course
i ripped my [ __ ] my shirt off and drank
a beer and started banging on the glass
going tarps off for the boys and the
hockey players are all laughing and it's
great great moment when i get back and
my daughter's like i got to sit next to
you for the rest of this game
like you're the one who just ripped his
shirt off killed a beer and started
everyone's staring at us and i was like
yeah i know what what are you worried
about she was like
like she doesn't
does she date is she dating i don't know
i don't i don't i don't know you really
don't know i really don't know the 17
year old i don't know are you okay no
you didn't know what i was doing no no
but did does it scare you that you'd go
out with i i don't i you know i
i i don't know i haven't really thought
i shut down because i i know that if she
heard me talk she is
she's very litigious about what gets
shared litigious she has a lawyer no
that's way like certain things she's not
cool with me sharing you just told me
you shared her period i did well that's
how i learned
[Laughter]
what did you say i saw georgia my oldest
when she got her period it was very
traumatic she's a very sensitive child
so she got her period she realized her
childhood was over right and she wasn't
ready for it to end that day
and she came in
and to leanne and started crying and
said i'm not ready to be a big girl
today like i'm not ready i don't i need
a couple more days playing with dolls i
get that and yeah but well
because i get it and and i think it's a
beautiful moment and that's why i want
to show you a beautiful moment meaning
meaning like an it's an insightful
moment for a child to have
upon
the entry into womanhood it's an
insightful moment so i want to share
that with you because i think it's
interesting and cool it is and then it
and then it tags even better because
isla witness georgia go through that and
go that's just not happening to me i'm
not going to deal with it like that so
isla got a period she did herself a
period party she
two different people call from the same
home she called me up and she goes hey
uh
we she told me when george got her
period she got elegant in the pool with
me she goes uh just so you know i'm not
getting my period and i was like
good luck with that
and so then one day she calls she goes
it happened i tried to stop it dad it
happened they didn't tell me did you
tell me when you got your period no no i
didn't tell anyone yeah george and then
isla was at school and she goes i need
to go to the store
and why is she calling you and not her
mother uh leanne was out they called the
house lee isla had gone through the i
led gone to the um to the uh principal
or whatever the firm she got a period
right she goes to the infirmary or
whatever thing says hey i need to go to
my locker and get my go bag my mom gave
me a go bag i got my period and they're
like do you need to call parents call
the house called me and i answered and
she was like
she was like uh hey we're just giving
you a heads up i got my period but i
need you go to the store i was like for
what she goes i need to get a red velvet
cake because i'm throwing a period party
tonight i was like what the [ __ ] is this
red velvet cake dad by everything red
we're throwing a period party i'm
fighting 10 girls and two boys and i was
like what what are you talking about
what i wanted to talk to the period
party she goes dad i'm gonna celebrate
it i'm gonna name my period uh we're
gonna party uh all the girls know but
the boys won't know why they're there
and how do you choose the boy two boys
max carter they were there they don't
know why they were there i put it on
instagram i put it all on instagram
because it was [ __ ] hilarious so i
met and got a red velvet velvet cake i
got spaghetti and meatballs i got
red kool-aid i got red wine i got
everything red everything was red
everyone wore red except for the two
boys the boys were like why is everyone
wearing red and the girls were laughing
hysterically and then we brought the
cake and she named her period jason
because she got it on friday the 13th
and so
these boys are like who the [ __ ] is
jason
and they're eating red velvet cake it's
all over their faces and the girls are
crying laughing
and so
i thought it was a brilliant story i
think it's brilliant to share of how one
sensitive insightful my poetic daughter
georgia my one will be a writer versus
my party animal isla who's like oh [ __ ]
that i'm throwing a period party tip off
the old block yeah so i shared it on
conan and and uh and without really
thinking i i just it was a good story
and i'm and you know you're sharing it
now oh yeah yeah yeah i put it on my
special because i shared it on conan and
then and they were like and i was like
oh
guys i talk about your period party you
know how sometimes you'll tell a bit to
your kids and go i talk about you in one
of these bits and then you forget oh i
talk kind of all over the map about you
oh [ __ ] and so i was like i talked about
your period party on conan and i was
like
did you wait you talked about my period
i'm coming in and i was like well no
your period party and she goes that was
my period
you're gonna like it it's good conan
loved it and then i tell it and then she
her first reaction was
georgia was like
why did you have to tell anything about
me and i was like because you're the
fact that you were so sensitive about it
highlights isla's we needed you for the
setup you're the setup you're the
leverage to the humor
without you i can't do i just looks like
a lunatic
and so uh
then isla started watching isla goes
she hits pause on the tv and she goes
you're making fun of me
i said no i'm not she goes no you are
you're making me look like i'm weird for
doing this and i go hold on baby it is
weird like no not a lot of people think
this way so i'm not making funny i'm
just highlighting that you're different
and i go i'm highlighting you're
different yeah i'm not making fun of you
and so that's another way of saying i'm
making fun of you they watched it and it
was kind of mixed they were like it was
it was cool it's good i'm glad and then
the next morning
i had
20 emails
and then the day after that i had 120
and then the day after that i had like
700 and the clip went viral like 20
million views within the first week and
you sold out red rocks
but uh little girls were having their
parents hit my email and say and the
little girl would write the letter this
letters to isla thank you so much for
letting your dad share your story oh my
older sister was like georgia and we
threw a period party last night for
and welcomed doug into our family and so
all the little girls were naming their
periods and then isla read these and was
like oh this is a good thing i said yes
the whole time i thought it was good and
i thought it should be shared because
they're if george is going through that
the most amazing back peddler you really
are yeah
[Music]